[Music]
all right let's go out to Georgia and
talk to Kristen what's up
Kristen hey how are you Dr John good
what are you up to I'm just sitting here
at my house buing laundry live in the
dream that's right the dream laundry
just keeps happening right it does yes
oh gosh man folding laundry it just
feels seemed like the most feudal thing
all right so what's up how can it help
so I written in um previously to ask if
you thought it would be a good idea if I
spoke with my ex-husband's new
girlfriend about
his no well there's an update because I
actually did meet with her and talk to
her why why did you do
that well I just I it was just something
the the great the great Frozen
she sang it back well who was it was it
Elsa Elsa sang it best yeah just let it
go oh my gosh I can't believe you did
that okay all right
so oh man so you have an ex-husband he's
dating again you love that and you felt
the need were you trying to warn her
about something I was trying to warn her
that he is abusive oh yes gosh okay and
I had spoken to like a mutual contact
between her and me and just to like get
some advice and the Mutual contact was
like you know if it was me I would want
to know and I kind of felt the same way
if it was me I'd want to know um and
what kind of what kind of abuse physical
abuse like um emotional abuse he's just
annoying he lies a lot emotional and and
verbal abuse um I think if we had stayed
together it probably would have turned
physical because he was punching walls
and kicking dogs and and that type of
thing um
so all right so you did something I
would have told you don't do call in
next time don't ask a mutual whatever
all right so you did it you've done it
how did it go it went really well I
really like her she's she's great she's
uh very kind and gracious and we sat and
had coffee for uh about an hour and and
talked about it and um she she thanked
me for you know letting her know and she
definitely she said she hadn't seen any
signs of that and uh of course she
hasn't of course exactly because I mean
we we just got divorced like the divorce
he filed in February of this year was
finalized in May and they started dating
in I guess June or July of this year oh
they were did they were together before
that that's what I'm thinking they were
together before that yes okay so I have
to ask this question
do did did it feel
better cuz I know there's a part of you
yes that wanted to warn a fellow sister
out there this is this might come but I
also know a big part of this was I can't
freaking believe he's already dating
again he ruined my life he's not getting
away with this a second
time it wasn't I mean I and I and I told
her that I'm very happy for the both of
them like I wish them the best and I
pray for him every day I pray for them
them together every day uh so it's it's
not a jealousy thing I I kind of wish it
was I feel like it would be easier to
get over if I was just jealous of her um
but she has four kids and she's also a
foster mom and I was like you I just
felt that and I kept praying about it
and it just would not
leave the back of my mind that you know
if if it was me i' I would want to know
and that I just and I told her I said I
just I don't want anybody to ever suffer
the way that I have suffered um from all
of it yeah so so that was just kind of
you did it so what's your question
now maybe maybe you don't even have one
you just want to sh wanted to share well
I just wanted to know your opinion but
you you let that go real real fast um I
the only time I've ever seen this
fruitful is when it comes the other
way when a new girlfriend or a new
fiance or a new um you know a guy's
about to get married and there's kids in
involved so you've got you know I don't
know if you do you all have kids
together yes okay so there's kids
involved and the abuse happened in front
of the kids and that that was part of my
thing is like you know she has kids and
foster kids and he had no problem doing
all of this in front of the kid sure
um man there's so many layers here um if
if you don't have a shred of jealousy
and maybe jealousy is the wrong word but
if you don't have a shred of Vengeance
in you um you're better than like you're
better off than
999998 per of
humanity yeah I I don't at all I really
she she is so good and I I told her I
was like I really hope that like maybe
you are what makes him change and makes
him better like for the kids sake and
everything I mean she and for her she's
like I know this is awkward but it
really it wasn't awkward for me sure I
just wanted to warn her but I mean she's
great I mean I I really like her and I I
hope that they what's the what's the
custody arrangement with your kids and
him um he gets them every first third
and fifth weekends and he gets them
every Thursday night on his off weekends
as well so Thursday to Sunday first
third and Fifth and every Thursday night
okay um the only way I've ever seen it
work really well is if two people sit
down to talk about the
kids like you're like my husband's
dating you my kids are going to be in
your life here's my expectations about
my kids I want to get to know the person
who's going to be in the life of my
children I've seen that go well when
people and when everybody's acting like
adults I've seen it be a nightmare when
people are acting like children people
act like adults then I I've seen it go
well people are respectful I've heard of
um men sitting down and saying you're
about to be in the life of my daughter
because you're now dating my ex-wife and
um here's my expectations for the men in
the life of my daughter and then I've
I've heard a couple of times the other
man the new boyfriend and the new fiance
be very respectful like I'm I'm
appreciative that her dad loves her this
much and you've got my word and I'll
call you like all that kind of stuff um
and then I've heard in a couple of rare
cases when somebody calls and says hey
this is a very personal private
conversation this guy's screaming at me
and swearing in front of my kids is this
new or did you experience this
too right I've never seen it go well the
other way the way you the way you did it
so maybe this is the first time ever um
I would be stunned if she doesn't reach
out and be like so your ex-wife called
and said you're abusive and that that
just end real
well right
so has he reached out to you and like
dude what's your
problem no he hasn't at all I don't know
if she's talked to him about it or not
um I told her that I went into this with
the assumption that whatever I say would
make it back to him yeah she would be a
terrible girlfriend if she
didn't so I I have
if she has told him he has not said
anything to
me oh
man um why didn't the courts side with
you we did mediation uhhuh um why did
you let me say it this way if he was so
abusive that you felt the need to go to
his new girlfriend and say watch out for
your own safety and at this time not
physical safety but own psychological
safety and the sheetrock in your house
safety why did you settle in a mediation
for anything less than this this monster
can't be around my
kids I was being told by my lawyer that
that would not happen um and I have uh
hours of evidence of it towards the end
I mean it got it got uh pretty bad to
the point where he accused me of
molesting our son um and apparently it
just didn't matter uh cuz that was one
of the things that I was upset about
after mediation with with what he he got
and they said well it that's that's the
best you would have gotten if you had
gone to court um I totally disagree with
that if the abuse was as real as if the
abuse was so egregious if it was a guy
yelling in his house and saying and
swearing in his house some judges might
not say that's abusive enough to take
away a kid from his
parent but if it's Vol as you said it
was so much that you need to be
proactive with his new
girlfriend I think you may have got bad
legal advice or your attorneys looked at
what you're experiencing and they were
like it's not as bad as you think it
is yeah and I I had told my attorney
that I wished uh that he had hit me
because people would take it more
seriously no you don't no I mean but in
because I felt like nobody was taking me
seriously nobody was listening um when
it happened yeah and
but it was I mean I was letting
everything roll off my back as it
happened because they made us live
together during the divorce part and um
he just attacked me every single day
just about they can't make you live
together yeah they they told us that we
couldn't leave I I kept begging my
lawyer I was like I sent email after
email with you know the evidence I was
like you know it's
getting nobody nobody they can't you're
not under house arrest they can't make
you stay in an apartment or in a home
with they said it would not go well if I
left because I kept asking if we could
move out and they said no and they told
him the same thing that it would look
bad if we if we moved out um so we what
would look bad hun that's
insane I have no
idea I guess when it came because we had
to sell the house so I guess when it
came to taking a stake of the equity
like I would
be I'm not sure what if you moved into
an apartment to keep from getting your
your brain beat in that's
nonsense I mean he he would uh call me
every name under the sun and like
discusting everything that's just the
most in I've never heard that in my life
ever there there has to be something
else here that I don't know about I've
never heard that in my life ever ever
ever in fact I again I don't know the
ins and outs of this case and I'm not a
legal professional but I can see a great
case for in the middle of mediation you
move out cuz it's so not
safe and that becomes part of the
mediation that he's created such a
hostile living environment for you but
again I'm not in there it doesn't sound
right at all I've never ever heard that
in this particular situation there's a
couple of things that have happened that
I've never ever ever heard ever and I've
seen some been around some wild
situations um and may that doesn't mean
anything that that maybe means this
happens all the time and it just goes
swep under the rug and swep under the
rug and swep under the rug
if I'm you I can't recommend it enough
that you've said your peace you've
talked to his new girlfriend and this is
the end of the road for that
conversation um if you feel the need to
have a conversation about your kid's
safety or working with some of your kids
I'd recommend you do it with your
husband or your ex-husband and let that
be that and if you get signs of abuse or
if your kids come home and say dad's
punching holes in the sheetrock again I
want you to call another attorney and
walk them through every single thing you
experienced and everything you went
through and say I can't have my kids
around this anymore I want to file suit
for a new custody Arrangement because my
children aren't
safe but I My Hope Is that you create
another life and you don't know his
dating
status unless he invites you in or
unless he's bringing somebody else home
around your kids and then you need to
know that but I want you to separate
your life from his
you need time to heal and you need time
to this whole thing just sounds like a
mess and I would pull myself out of it
and I would focus my time on my kids and
on my kids safety and he's going to go
do what he's going to go do I hate that
you're in this man it's just such a
messy messy
mess and it just sounds like you got
some gross advice or there's just other
parts of the story but I wish you the
best and I wish that you begin let let
there be a period at the end of this
sentence and and go on about healing and
creating your new life because you're
worth peace and right now you don't have
that